(soft electronic music)
- So without further ado,
I'm going to introduce
Karen Gaffney.
I think her reputation precedes herself.
She is amazing, truly inspiring.
And her talent and energy
leads to extraordinary accomplishments.
She also is dedicated to
the well-being of others.
She is a heroine in
every sense of the word.
Many of you may know
this, some of you may not.
She is an English Channel relay swimmer.
She's taken this journey
to champion the journey
for all people with Down syndrome.
It's really inspiring,
and it really inspires
inclusion for all people.
I would just like to say that
your long-distance swimming,
it's evidence that it's
possible that each person
can meet their potential.
Please join me in welcoming Karen Gaffney.
(audience applauding)
- [Karen] Thank you for
a nice introduction.
(microphone feedback)
That's not me. (laughs)
Good morning everyone.
- [Audience] Good morning.
- In early January I
received an email from a mom,
who's expecting her second child in May.
She contacted me because
just before Christmas,
she found out that her baby would be born
with Down syndrome.
In her email, she told me
that she was devastated.
She cried a lot.
I'm sure you can all relate to that
because she didn't know
much about Down syndrome.
But what she did know from
her doctor wasn't good.
In fact, it was scary.
After a few days, she went to the internet
and that's where she found me,
and many others just like me.
She told me in her email
that she was very hopeful
after learning more about the
real story on Down syndrome.
Many people in the medical community
and the prenatal testing industry will say
that Down syndrome is
not compatible with life.
Only they don't say it just like that.
They will say trisomy 21
instead of Down syndrome
is not compatible with life
because it sounds more
scientific that way, and fearful.
If they say Down syndrome,
then people will start to think
about all the people they
know, maybe a cousin,
an aunt, or an uncle,
maybe the person who
lives across the street
or works at their local grocery store
or at the same company they do,
goes to school with their
daughter, is on a swim team
with their son, or sits
behind them in church.
Maybe they remember someone
in their high school class.
I know all of you here know
someone with Down syndrome.
So think about us for just a minute.
Are we not compatible with life?
As soon as I heard from
the mom, I emailed her back
right away with all sorts
of stories about my friends
with Down syndrome.
And I showed her this picture,
12-year-old Ben Silverman,
carving the waves of the Pacific Ocean.
She told me that she was crying again,
but this time they were tears of hope.
Oh, did I mention to you
that Ben has Down syndrome?
(audience laughs)
I wonder how those in the
prenatal testing industry
measure compatible.
It is a mystery to me.
Maybe they should try to explain it
to Ben, but they'll
have to catch him first.
(audience laughs)
It's okay, I know I am different than you.
I look differently, I talk
differently, I walk differently.
I don't hear as well as most of you do,
and I don't see as well either.
And sometimes it takes me
longer to learn things.
Now, another thing that
is different about me
is that I can swim, like
longer and much farther
than anyone in this room.
(audience laughs and applauds)
You may be faster than me at the start,
but I will outlast you
on time and distance
any day of the week.
(audience laughs)
You should know that I
have some pretty big swims
on my resume, like a relay
across the English Channel,
a nine mile nonstop
swim across Lake Tahoe,
a six mile swim down the
Columbia River to raise funds
for the Providence Center
for the Medically Fragile Children,
in Portland, Oregon where I live.
I also like to tell people
that I am the first person
with Down syndrome to
escape from Alcatraz.
(audience laughs and applauds)
I have done that swim
from Alcatraz Island,
where the prison used to
be, all the way across
the San Francisco Bay 16 times now.
(audience exclaiming)
And unlike some famous prisoners
who have attempted that swim,
I have lived to tell about it.
(audience laughs)
I have done many other open water swims,
in Thunder Lake, the Boston Harbor,
Dun Laoghaire Harbor in Dublin, Ireland,
a five mile swim from Molokini
to Wailea Beach in Maui.
And an eight and a half
mile swim from Vermont
to New York on Lake Champlain, twice.
I swim two miles a day, and
I work out on weights too.
But I haven't done a big
open water swim in a while.
So, I'd be up for a challenge.
(audience laughs)
I grew up swimming, but I also grew up
knocking on the doors to
inclusion in the classroom.
I was lucky enough to have been included
in a regular classroom all
through my school years.
We had to change schools
to make it happen,
but I made it.
I have a regular high school diploma
from St. Mary's Academy,
and a two year college degree
from Portland Community College,
along with a teacher's aide certificate.
I worked for a while as a teacher's aide,
but now I'm currently
working 20 hours a week
at Oregon Health Sciences University,
and I created that role.
And on Fridays, I'll work my
Down syndrome clinic there.
I met with families and their children,
help in the PT room, and I
answer a lot of questions
about living with Down syndrome.
When I'm not at OHSU or at the pool,
I work on projects for my nonprofit.
Over the last 10 years, I
have talked with audiences
all around the country
and all around the world
about the importance
of inclusive education
for people like me with Down
syndrome or other disabilities.
I have shared my experiences
and helped to influence changes
and raise expectations of others
about what people like me can accomplish.
I also talk about the importance
of regular exercise for everyone,
but especially for people like me.
(clears throat)
You know, in the last 60 years,
because of people just like you,
and families just like yours,
we have changed the course
of life for people like me.
It wasn't easy, and it still isn't.
There are still battles
to fight for inclusion
in too many classrooms around the world.
And breakthroughs haven't
come for everyone.
But, the progress is tremendous.
All over the country, all over the world,
we have young people with Down syndrome
graduating from their high schools,
some going on to colleges,
learning employable job skills,
knocking on the doors of your companies.
We have musicians and artists,
actors and fashion models.
We have black belts in Taekwondo.
We have public speakers.
We have golfers, we have surfers,
hockey players, and open water swimmers,
and some of us have even
escaped from Alcatraz.
(audience laughs)
Now, all right, now I know that all sounds
pretty compatible with
life, don't you think?
- [Audience] Yes.
(audience applauding)
- You know, it is people just like you
that are making this
happen for people like me.
Now, just as we are
making so much progress,
we have some huge waves coming our way
threatening to wipe us out.
One of those waves is prenatal screening.
You see, a whole industry has grown up
and the race is on to
find newer, faster ways
to test for Down syndrome before birth,
and you screen us out.
Yes, screen us out.
Efforts are underway to create
a world without Down syndrome
through abortion, and I
think that it is wrong.
It is very, very wrong.
Down syndrome is being targeted
because it is one of
the easiest tests to do.
All you have to do is count chromosomes.
Without timely and accurate information
about all our progress,
if the test shows an extra chromosome,
in many countries around the world,
pregnancies are being terminated,
babies are being aborted.
Except with those who say,
"I know a different Down syndrome,"
or "wait a minute, let me
learn more about this."
And those parents have to push back
on the medical community that
is quick to advise abortion
instead of education and learning
about the real story on Down syndrome.
Even though we have support
groups all over the world,
we still have experts advising families
with old and outdated data,
data that reflects the past,
data that is rooted in the past
and reflects what happened
in the life then in an institution
and they are wrong.
They are very, very wrong.
Thankfully we have, (clears throat)
thankfully we have some
ways of our own pushing back
on the prenatal testing industry.
And one of those ways is medical research.
We have dedicated leaders on
teams here at UC San Diego,
at the Linda Crnic Institute in Denver,
at the (speaks indistinctly)
Foundation and many
others around the world
that are focused on finding ways to fight
the bad effects of that extra chromosome.
These organizations don't
want to screen us out,
they want to fix what is hurting us,
and they are working
night and day to outrun
the prenatal testing industry.
We need to give them all the help we can
because we are racing for our lives.
We need this medical research,
ladies and gentlemen,
the kind of medical
research that is focused
on the causes of our learning problems,
our speech problems, our memory problems,
as well as the huge
threat many of us face,
and that is the early onset
of Alzheimer's disease.
It seems this extra
chromosome we all share
puts us at a much greater risk
for the early onset of Alzheimer's
than the general population.
I am close to the age when
those of us with Down syndrome
are most vulnerable, and quite frankly,
I am scared by that.
I have worked so hard, (clears throat)
(breathing heavily) to
get where I am today.
And so have many other
young people my age.
Sorry.
It is my generation that
is showing what is possible
because of the hard work of
the generations before us.
But it is also my generation
that is marching directly
into the ugly path
of Alzheimer's disease.
And if that happens, there
is no road back for us.
It is a huge black cloud
that hangs over us,
and our families.
I think it is important for
families to stay current
on what is going on in medical research
and learn more about
what they can do to help.
You're lucky to have the UC
San Diego research efforts
right here where you live.
And you are very fortunate
that UC San Diego
is on the leading edge of research
on Down syndrome and Alzheimer's.
I hope you all, wait, sorry,
I hope you will all get
behind the efforts here
because our future depends on it.
My friend who's expecting her baby in May
emailed me back again this week.
She told me she was going to
name her baby Holly Karen.
(audience murmurs)
And that made me smile.
Who knows, maybe she'll be a swimmer.
(audience laughs)
Or a surfer like Ben Silverman.
Or even better, a medical research.
So, Dr. Mobley, Dr. Rafii,
and (speaks indistinctly)
I hope you get this Alzheimer's
thing fixed sometime soon.
Otherwise a young lady named Holly Karen
or a young man named Ben Silverman
just might have to do it for you.
Thank you.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauding)
(soft electronic music)